hi everyone thank you again uh for uh
being here with us
uh and it's really my pleasure to
introduce to you all
vitalik buterin uh thank you vitalik for
joining us here for this fireside chat
thank you brian it's great to be here so
we first met in 2015
in san francisco on your original road
show for the ethereum ico
and i was really impressed by the vision
for the ethereum ecosystem
and it's one of my greatest regrets in
life not having jumped in with a small
bit of investment that day
i admit i was completely daunted by the
prospect of what you were building and i
didn't think it was possible
so when we met a year later in shanghai
it was clear that i was mostly wrong
and in my new role at hyperledger i was
intent on making sure that we didn't
second-guess this community
being built even while hyperledger was
set to really explore the more
permission side of the blockchain space
these days i like to think that while
we're more full spectrum at hyperledger
with hyperledger bay zoo and other
efforts the bridge of these two worlds
um you know so what we're here to do is
talk about the future of ethereum and
how it relates to this thing called the
enterprise
uh but i want to start on those early
days so let me ask even before
ethereum kicked off you participated in
the early days
in the development of the bitcoin
ecosystem and the bitcoin code base
what was it about those early days of
that that open source community around
bitcoin
that made it so accessible to to a young
vitalik
and i think one of the fascinating
things about the bitcoin community early
on
is just how it managed to attract and
bring together like many very different
kinds of people
right because like crypto as a whole is
itself a very multidisciplinary thing
right you have the cryptography
you have the math you have the economics
you have the monetary theory you have
the social and political
um implications and you have businesses
trying to do things with
it and there are definitely many
different people like even back
in the community in 2011 that just came
at it from
all of these different perspectives
right and you know sometimes the
perspectives were very different and you
know there was even some uh
a healthy and vigorous uh debate on the
bitcoin forums uh that
back in 2011 this was you know back
before they were even called big one
talk
and you know i was interested in a lot
of things at the time like
i've always been interested in math i've
been interested in cryptography i was
interested in economics as well
also you know interested in i guess the
bigger questions of uh life and the
human civilization
uh so the big way in the community
it definitely had uh some of all of that
and it was just a a great forum to just
talk with other people that had all of
these
different and interesting ideas and then
also there were
there was this just a vibrant community
of uh people that was just
you know willing to come in and help and
uh build whatever needed to be built
right like
you know we needed to build um a bitcoin
client and there was this community of
core developers that was working on and
improving their client
uh we needed to build bitcoin wallets
people came in and just
made wallets and you know you needed a
way for people to see what's going on in
the blockchain people just came in and
built block explorers
so there was this great uh kind of
community collaborative feeling there at
the time which
i definitely really like and that's
definitely one of the things that i
definitely really value and kind of care
about really trying to support an
ethereum as well
yeah yeah well sometimes when us when we
in the open source community talk about
um that about the community and about
how things work we can sometimes
sometimes i'm guilty of making it sound
like spontaneous combustion
you know like these things just happened
and we didn't know why or how
um but when you think about the the
ethereum ecosystem now and like the role
that the foundation is playing and and
others are there
specific things like you think about or
or that they think about in terms of
helping foster the the right kind of
community around especially the the
development the open source community
around the development of ethereum
um i mean i think uh
it's having a good open source community
definitely a guide like
there's a lot of different ingredients
that i think
you need to get right like one of them
is
um just that like the ecosystem needs to
be one that's kind of open and welcoming
and like if someone wants to come in and
contribute they
get actually can go do that um
like it's definitely easy to just even
accidentally fail at that and like
accident
accidentally just you know end up either
driving away contributors when you don't
needs to
or just like not making it clear that
there's things where people just that
can go in and participate
um also and i think ethereum has been
kind of successful just because of what
it
is right like it's not asia a kind of
you know finite bounded system in the
sense of just you know here's one thing
that you can do with it and like you
know
this is money or this is a domain name
system or like this is one thing
um it's an open platform and people can
just uh
you know go into and like build their
own make interesting and amazing things
and just like having that space is um
also i think
important for having an ecosystem that
developers are excited about
um also and i think there's
just like you do have to get the
get the economics right like and this is
one of the challenges of this
community is right like especially with
crypto that like
on the one hand um well like i think
like the biggest difference i think
between
like crypto projects in the ecosystem
and say the open source ecosystem of
you know the early 2000s is that like
there's money involved
and there is like a significant amount
of money for kind of
floating around you know you got the
coins and the coins go up and then the
coins go down
and then and then there's new coins and
there's new points going up and down
uh and on the one hand like this means
that you actually have
an opportunity to like try to even pay
people like
compensate people who are doing really
important work um
which you know i think is important
right like you can rely on volunteers
for some things you can rely on
volunteers for smaller projects but
and the the challenge with
a kind of just relying on volunteers
instead of going forever is that
like first of all you know you're not
all this is going to
necessarily attract enough people and
also like if you have this ecosystem
where like some people are contributing
for free but then other people are
making millions out of it like that just
feels very unfair to people right and
like that is a legitimate challenge
though for the
the crypto space as well right that like
sometimes you do have this imbalance and
like you make this one valuable tool and
like okay maybe you can get a grant but
then you make this uh
other thing where like you you've come
up with a way to stick a coin in the
middle of it and
uh you know you get like 25 million
dollars if you see investment flying at
you
and like that's an imbalance and
and we've definitely tried to do our
best to address that imbalance and like
at the same time as um you know trying
to
prevent like the adhering foundation
itself from sort of being an overly
dominant pull in the ecosystem
so that's also a challenge um another
important challenge is just like
appealing to the kind of diverse
community like
you know not everyone that might wants
to contribute speech english that's
probably
the most obvious example and like just
making you know our contents
documentation everything's like
accessible a lot in
different languages trying to actually
engage with all the local communities is
something that we've
valued and we're trying to do for a long
time as well
cool well yeah there's so many different
pressures at play and and compared to
like the idyllic early days of apache or
linux or something like that it
sometimes feels like
these pressures can really create such a
such an intense kind of pressure cooker
environment um
uh some of those pressures increasingly
i feel like they might be coming from
people trying to adopt these
technologies for enterprise uses
you know i think of the enterprise i
think of star trek or whatever is kind
of this almost
you know impossibly big or menacing
thing but uh but really some of these
are for very prosaic use cases right for
settlement systems for
for um regulatory reporting or auditing
that sort of thing
how much are those pressures on the
backs of the
core ethereum developers how much are
you thinking about this you know
especially with the
design for ethereum two were these kinds
of use cases and needing to support
those use cases on your minds as you're
you're designing the f2
design yeah and i think like enterprise
users of blockchains are definitely
really important and
and i think like the big the biggest way
in which
um eth2 in particular can help
enterprises is just having more
scalability
right that's because uh you know right
now transaction fees are high
and one of the challenges with a
transaction fees being high
is that like first of all it just prices
out users but like it prices out
different kinds of users differently
right like
it i think the people who get priced out
first often are
just like you know the people that wants
to use the blockchain for uh doing basic
non-financial things like whether it's
you know supply chain tracking or even
things like ens or
just about everything that's not moving
high value crypto tokens around
and so when the fees go up to ten
dollars like you know all that's left is
like
well there's some high value domains and
then there's like a lot of moving crypto
tokens around
our vision in ethereum has always been
to
be this platform that's open to all of
these different um applications where
you know the limit is just your
creativity but
if in practice just the economics make
it so it's only viable to do a few
things then in some ways that's like a
big limitation on
how much of our mission we can actually
accomplish so you know
the dream of scalability right is you
know we have roll ups and
ropes already exist for some
applications and now general purpose
roll-ups are coming very soon right like
arbitrarily recently yeah released their
uh uh
thing on main net and then optimism has
a kind of limited uh rollout on
maintenance that they've been slowly
expanding over time
zk sync has been making god great
progress right um
and at the same time we've been working
on charting which kind of improves the
base layer itself so that
um at the base where you have something
like 100 times more scalability right so
shorting times 100 roll up times 100 the
two multiplied times 10 thousand and
like
the hope is that you can simultaneously
like
make the platform able to handle more
users and
like reduce transaction fees right and
so yeah
it's like supply and demand right you
have more supply and so
you know you don't have like all of
these users
kind of bidding against each other so
hard so if transaction fees can go down
then you know we're hoping by a factor
of uh
uh of a hundred but we'll see but then
that like opens the door for all of
these other
applications again and like there are a
lot of people you know even in
enterprise that even wants to use the
public ship right like there's
you know like ey and like the the
nightfall
i think it was like the baseline
protocol there's all of these amazing
groups trying to
like do public chain based um enterprise
things
and again i get like i definitely
believe in kind of
the public chain i guess because like i
i don't even know what wants to see a
future where you know
like enterprise and kind of you know the
people have to be these kind of two
different poles that
are you know either different universes
are kind of viewed as opposing each
other like you know we should have an
ecosystem where you know the enterprises
and everyone they can just all
live together and uh you know the
ecosystems can kind of plug into each
other and benefit each other much more
and and then but the challenge is that
you know if you want anyone to be
building on the public chain then
you know the transaction fees have to go
down and then also privacy issues have
to be solved and
and that's like the other benefit right
like you have all of these like very
diverse different groups like just
building and working on this technology
and like everyone can just use each
other's stuff
ideally right um so
i'm optimistic about that future good
good and you mean it isn't as easy as
just increasing the block size by 10x
no no elon said it was so i thought i
thought that was that that was that was
the case
um and obviously one of the big changes
coming up in ethereum too is the move
from proof of work to proof of stake
which um you know a lot of people are
concerned about the energy consumption
of uh
of maine ed of cryptocurrencies in
general um
you know how much was uh the
environmental concerns on your mind
as you were designing to a uh is the
move
largely driven by that or were there
were there other motivations
um and i think i think it was def it's
definitely a major reason why people
wants to move over
um i think like the the consequences of
um you know the amount of like
energy and even just stuff that proof of
work systems consume are pretty
significant right like and
people like often talk about you know
the energy waste aspect but then
there's also uh like first of all you
know even if you're using amazing solar
power
you know you're still which
you know there's not everyone else like
you're still
taking away energy that could be used by
other people and like you know we've
seen like in iran
the the government's been angry because
of like electricity being displaced from
local villages and so forth and then
there's hardware and hardware has its
own environmental costs uh so
going from that to a consensus model
where
the the economics are fully virtualized
which is you know what proof of stake is
right like we've even talked about like
proof of stake validators just being
kind of like virtual miners right
um you know they're like miners except
you know it's all kind of digital and
just simulated by the system and and
that just like completely solves all of
these problems so you know we don't even
have to argue about them and we don't
have to just like get into these lengthy
debates of like you know who's using
coal and who's using solar and like is
the solar actually solar and all of this
stuff like no just like
making yes that's the word you know the
the resource get requirements
as a whole or just more than a thousand
times lower like that's
definitely i think it's definitely a big
um a big motivation for us
and obviously of course at the same time
there is kind of the more selfish factor
which is that
if you uh reduce like the fact that you
need so much
electricity and like hardware like you
also need to pay for that stuff
and to pay for that stuff you just have
to like print a huge number of coins
and that like you know it does
risk the the economic sustainability of
the system of kind of the
you have to choose between you know
either the supply of coins just kind of
continuing to go up non-stop
or between potentially risking um
security going down to
low levels and like once again you know
with the proof's sake we don't have that
trade-off uh so
i think you know it's uh
good for the good for the ethereum
community good for the users good for
the world
it's always great when things line up
that way yeah that's great
and um just a a as a wrap-up question
what's what is the one technology you
think
uh in the ethereum ecosystem as a whole
that you're most excited about
when it uh when you think about the
needs of enterprises or the needs of
getting this uh kind of infrastructure
adopted by
by the mainstream of society
what kind of infrastructure um i think
like some of the higher level stuff that
i'm
most concerned about so i think like
we've talked about privacy uh
and like and i've talked about it a lot
previously as well and it's definitely
important right like
you know you don't want i know twitter
for your bank account right um
and like the nice thing about like
combining blockchains and cryptography
is that you have a lot of room to just
like make all of these like
different compromises between them you
know privacy and what your other goals
are
you can kind of much more freely define
like what it is you're actually getting
and at the same time you know the
blockchain has this verifiability and
auditability so
you know if you like need
like if you want need like whether for
an audit or investigation or something
like prove that you know here's
things that happened before and like
look i did every i i did everything the
way i was supposed to be doing like you
you can and you can just kind of
selectively reveal whatever information
you want right like so
there's a great future for like
improving privacy
um security i think is also important
right like
i still remember and uh frequently
linked back to
the bitcoin magazine article i wrote in
2013 this was like
a bitcoin wallet security uh and
then there were these uh kind of
nightmare stories of uh
you know a guy has a half a million
dollars a bitcoin and then he wakes up
and then he doesn't have half a million
dollars of bitcoin what happens i don't
think we know yet
and you know there's you can have
someone's computer
someone's computer can get lost um if
you write the words down on a piece of
paper someone can steal the piece of
paper the piece of paper can get lost
um you know there's just all of these
things that can happen and
like i've talked about ideas like i've
talked about things like multi-sig
wallets and
social recovery wallets and all these
things to try to
like reduce the the risk that things
like that happen
and like actually make like
cryptographic keys or at least kind of
blockchain while it's
a more viable way of like authenticating
a person
and but you know it's this is
you know like i feel like we've seen
improv fairly big improvements over the
last uh three years as well
uh right and i feel like you know we're
gonna continue to see improvements in
the future so you know once again like
it's both
like for me a big concern and a worry
but it's also something that i'm
very excited about uh seeing fixed
because i know it is going to be fixed
yeah thank you so much vitalik i mean i
i'm reminded of the quote from uh
mahatma gandhi which is
first they ignore you then they laugh at
you then they fight you
and then you win and i see this pattern
repeated whether it's the early days of
the internet people were concerned we
can't use it for commercial purposes
because it's this research thing and
it's unreliable um then they said that
about open source software
i i you know there's that transition
point in like the late 90s where
it's like okay maybe we can use this for
enterprises um and i think
that's a similar transition point we're
at when it comes to thinking about the
full spectrum of blockchain technologies
and i think
the ethereum ecosystem is playing a key
role in that in that transition so
thank you so much for your time and uh
looking forward to talking
with you again soon yeah thank you brian
and thank you for just all the great
work you've been doing with hyperledger
very sweet thanks